hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan  Academy and I'm here to remind you that  we are a not-for-profit with a mission  of providing a free world-class  education for anyone anywhere we're not  for profit with the budget of a large  high school and our Ambitions and where  we're already reaching is in the  hundreds of millions and eventually  billions of Learners so if you believe  that the world needs an institution or  the world needs something on the  Internet that's creating more light than  heat then please think seriously about  donating the Khan Academy because we  really wouldn't be able to serve the  hundreds of millions to billions of  Learners without support from folks like  yourself